[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちはー
もしかしたら
こういう髪型なので
大学生から結構を間違われるんですけれども一応
さあリーマンです
これでも
陰謀で肌れましたん
たった3年前までは僕もここにいる多くの大学生のみなさんと一緒で授業とかレポート
に追われて
アルバイトサークルの飲み会を本気高木普通に楽しんでいる
大学生したしたった1年前までは銀行員だった頃朝は8時くらいに出社をして夜も80
ぐらいの比較をして夜中のページぐらいあげるって本当にごく普通のサラリーマン生活
も送っていました
おそらくここにいる多くの皆さんの中にも今同じ悩みを抱えている方もいるかもしれ
ませんが当時
こんな悩みも
抱えていました
やりたい事が
私が立教大学を卒業したときやり最後とな
一切なかったですし明確にやりたいことを見つけている友人もいませんでした
しかし
表話する
ある方法を実践したことでこんなを出してもやりたいことを見つけることができ今では
365日
毎日
好きなことに取り組め
そこで今日は
私が大学生だった頃に
聞きたかったお話をしたいと思います
何も難しいことは一切話しませ
やりたいことよりも
やりたくないことを
見つけを寄せ4話です
もしか者らの製氷この中にはに明確にやりたいことが見つかっていいよという方もいる
かもしれません
その場合いやりたいことがなかなか見つからないと
ご友人やご家族の方にこの話をシェアしていただければと思います
まずはじめに
やりたいことを見つける方法として一般的なものからお話ししていきたいとおもいます
皆さんは
やりたいことが見つからないと悩み誰かに相談をした時今までどんなアドバイスを
受けてきたことがありますか
僕は過去に
こんなアドバイスを受けたことがあります
とにかく
挑戦してみよう
これは僕にアドバイスをくれたその人だけでは79
ホリエモンあったりそのから有名な企業から全く同じことを言ってますトニー各挑戦を
してみてやりたいことを見つけているよ
このアドバイスというのは非常に
いにかなっていると思っています
なぜなら
人は自分の子っていうその範囲内か確か
やりたいことを見つけられないからです
例えば幼稚園生の将来の夢としてプロ野球選手になりたいとかサッカー選手になりたい
と言う
幼稚園生いますが
西弁護士になりたいとか
商社マンになりたい幼稚園生はいないと思います
それは幼稚園生の知っているその範囲国際便防止などが背景だ
このようにとにかく挑戦をして自分の知っている範囲を広げていけばやりたいことの
選択肢も増えて5したやりたいことが見つからぬ
この方法は間違っていないと思いますし私が大学3年生の頃にこのアドバイスを受けた
ときは絶対にこれだったら見つかると思いました
なので実際に大学3年生の頃は単四という思いでいたということもあって
大学4年時の1年間とさらにそれに休学を加えて合計2年間という時間
とにかく
言うようなことに挑戦しました
このスライドに書いてあるようなことです
it のベンチャー企業では約9が月が週5日1日8時間以上
必死働かせていただきましたしそこでは誰も挑戦したことのない領域でゼロから企画を
考えて周りを待つ頭に必死成果を出していきました
またそれが終わった後はヒッチハイクで日本一種のためにも出ていました
約6ヶ月間400台以上のクルマに乗らせていただいて運転手の壁や旅で出会った方に
必死にどんな人生に歳ですが将来の夢は何ですがやりたいことは何ですか必死に
いろいろ質問して自分の g 製のボールをモデルっていうのを見つけようとしました
し
それだけではなく旅の途中やカメラバッパリィ動画撮影だったりドキュメンタリー動画
作ってとにかく色々なことにそう人間母は
挑戦したんですけれどもそれでもやっぱり
やりたいことがあ
見つかりませんでした
2年たんです
ではなぜ
とにかく挑戦をして視野を広げたのにやりたいことが見つからなかったのかもしくは
やりたいことが見つかるのに時間がかかってしまうのか
理由は
確認をするのに時間がかかるからです
これは調整をしてからやりたいことを見つけるまでの過程リオ
5ステップの使いに落としこんなもんですよ
まず step 1挑戦してみる step 2
歩いケーキターン全力で打ち込む
デップさん無理なくできる step 4
好きになる最後にそれがやがてられたことです
ここで
ポイントなのは
step 2です
ある行ってきた全力で打つと思うこれはホイールを向いていますし私の実体験からそう
思いますが
ああああ一定きた全力で打ち込まないとそもそも好きか嫌いか判断できません
しかしゼロからある一定きた全力で打ち込む
それがもっちだったらまたゼロから気せんとしてある行ってきた全力勉
この繰り返しになるのでどうしても時間がかかってしまいます
このようにある一定期間全力で打ち込むという部分が時間がかかるという問題に
つながり
なかなかやりたいことが見つからないという問題に発展していけると考えています
ここで
やりたいことを見つける別の切り口として皆さんにおすすめしたいのが
やりたくないことを見つけようよっている方法です
この方法をお勧めする理由はやりないことへも比較的簡単にやりたくないことは
見つかりやすいだ
例えば
最近行った嫌な事ストレスが溜まる事嫌いだなと思ったこと
何でもいいのでもへ食べてみてください
例えばですが
満員電車0
大学に行くのは嫌だ仕事に甘いやだとか
のみ対応いサークルは嫌なとか
まあ往年階信念が多い会社を結構きついとか
アルバイトが嫌だなぁとか
ノルマが
厳しい会社はやろうとかとにかくやりたくない事っていうのは8 fa ことよりも
比較的簡単に洗い出すことができると思います
次にこのようにやりたくないほどっていうのを洗い出していけばやがてやりたいことが
見つかるよというお話をしていきたいと思う
例えば
皆さんに一つ思い浮かべていただきたいのは
チーズをた探しをイメージしてみてください
たからとがやりたいことです
さきほども言いましたが
やりたくない事っていうのは比較的簡単に見つかるのでこの地図上にここはやりたく
ないこと
ここには彼らはないなというふうに圧印をつけることができる
このようなイメージ雪
どんどんやりたくないことを見つけていけばどんどんこの地図上に
圧印ているをつけることができ罰じゃない場所が小さくなりやがて
だいたいこの辺りにやりたいことはあるなというふうに目星がつけられるん
私も実際にこのやりたくないことを見つけるという方法で
やりたいことを見つけることができました
銀行員時代はこのすらニーハイであるようなこと以上にとにかくやりたくないこと
だらけでした
日々本当にそいつがたまりましたし1日でも早く今から抜け出したいという思いが強く
なって動い切って銀行の辞めて自分の人生から
やりたくないとすべて解除していたです
そうすると
これだったら
無理なくできるなぁとか
俺何から好きだなーとかちょっとスピーカー
そういう生き方や働き方だけが選択肢として自分の人生に残っていたん
具体的には
このセラードに入るようなものです
俺も書きれていないですが例えば欺罔とワークで
場所に縛られずに働く
フレックス制度があって自分に縛られずに働く
田舎に自然が多いましょう働くとがそういったものです
フォース私が
大学生や
銀行員がた頃銀毛とワークやフレックス制度がある会社に働くことが自分にとって
ベストでありそれがやりたいことにつながっているのは一切思えませんさ
しかしやりたくないことに目を向けてやりたくない高靭性から排除していたからこそ
本当に心の底からやりたいと思うような選択肢竹下
残らないようになっていたんです
繰り返しになりますがやりたくないことを見つけてやりたくないことを人生から
どんどん排除していっ
そうすればやがてその時には気づかなかった
やりたいことが自分の人生の選択肢に残っていくようになります
ホワイエ中にはどうやってやりたくないことを見つければいいな
どうやって鎮静から効率よく排除していてばいいなという部分で疑問がある方もいると
思うので最後に
明日から実践できるアクションプランをご紹介します
たったの3ステップですきっ
まず step 1やりたくないことにスト100を作る
ステップに解決できるスキルを洗います
そして最後に step 3で愛知性を判断するために挑戦する
まずステップ市やりたくないことリスト100を作るです
とにかく自分は
いやだなあと思った事嫌いだなぁと思ったことストレスから感じだと思ったことを何で
もいいです支えるものでもいいので
洗い出してみてください
これは僕が感じたやりたくないことの一例ですが
些細なものでも結構ですこのやりたくないことを100個洗い出したものがやりたく
ないほどリスト100です
ここで一つポイントなぁは
自分の心には嘘をつかないということです
自分の心に嘘をついてリストをつくって針にそれを達成したとしても
一切心は満たされません
このようにやりたくないことを洗い出せば
洗い出すことにやがてやりたいことが見つかる可能性というのは深まっていくのでぜひ
やりたくないことリストを作ってみて下さい
そして
べっぷにっ
解決できるスキルを洗い出してみてください
僕の実体験をねぇいいお話をさせていただきます
やりたくないこととして例えばですが
毎朝早起きして仕事に行くのが嫌だなとか
あとは自分のタイミングで出社できないのが嫌だ
こういうやりたくないことに対して解決策は
時間にし生まれない働き方をすればいい
そしてその解決策を実行するスキルを洗い出した時にライティングスキルであったり運
マーケティングスキルだったりプログラミングスキルこういうスキルを洗い出すことが
できました
このようにやりたくないことに目を向けて解決策を考えて必要なスキルを考えるという
尺三色で
洗い出していけば自分が学ぶべきスキルや知識の方向性というのが明確に定まっていき
ます
そして最後に step 3
適性を判断するために挑戦してみてください
学生の方であれば在学中にぜひ
性を判断するために挑戦しほしいですし社会人の方もお忙しいとは思いますが
仕事が終わった後に是非そのスキルを習得することに時間を費やしてみてください
副業禁止の会社にあったとしてもスキルを身につけることだけであれば問題ないはず
です
やみくもに色々な事に強打して時間を使うのではなく
このようにやりたくないことを洗い出して必要なスキルを考えて適性を判断するために
挑戦しているというこの3ステップで逆算式で取り組んでいけば法律よく自分がやる
べき挑戦っていうのに取り組むことができます
最後にまとめです
このプレゼンで私が最もお伝えしたかったのはやりたいことよりもやりたくないことを
見つけようという方法です
理由はやりたくない事の方がやりたいことよりも比較的簡単に見つかりやすいからだ
そしてそのやりたくないことを見つけて人生から配布する方法っていうのはあったら3
ステップです
まず
step 1やりたくないことリスト100を作った
てっぷにっ
必要なスキル間す
step 3適性を判断する
このやりたいことを見つける方法というのは
私が見つけた一例にした過ぎませんが現在でも未来でも皆さんがなかなかやりたいこと
が見つからないと思い悩む画面があれば是非お試しいただければと思います
この私のアイディアが皆さんの想い覚えの人生を謳歌する少しでも減らす気になれば
嬉しい限りです
本日はご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]